For decades, Ash has been known across the Outlands as a ruthless killer,...
...unburdened by conscience.
But a dark secret lurks beneath the surface.
Hello, can anyone hear me?
Another consciousness is hidden away.
Help!
While Ash has little love for the Legends, in death they become useful.
And analyzing their death box will lead her to their killers.
You made a fatal error crossing me.
Inspired from her old Titan,...
...Ash can throw out a paralyzing snare to bind her prey,...
...allowing her to close in for a more personal finish.
You should have scurried away while you had the chance.
While Ash is a fearsome force from any distance,...
...her most terrifying power is the ability to tear through space itself.
Another precise execution.
I'll see you very soon.
And I will be the last thing you ever see.